ch c'est un nouveau toit comment
résister à ce jeu de mots à la veille de
l'ouverture de l'exposition
rétrospective de l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
du peintre cézanne au grand palais à
paris près de 200 tableaux de celui qui
révolutionna la peinture à la fin du
siècle dernier
ce qui est d'autant plus remarquable que
selon les critères disons académique de
la peinture cézanne n'est pas un bon
peintre georges bégoux pascal puis vu
d'avion c'est zen dans les nuages de
notre inconscience et des pommes
des joueurs de cartes des baigneuses
et la montagne sainte victoire qu'il a
si souvent arpenter dessinée est peinte
en variant les angles
mais que sait-on de ses débuts la
période qu'il appelait coup yard
il peignait alors en pleine pâte avec
des contours mal assurée il pratiquait
une sorte d'expressionnisme que sait-on
de cette interprétation de l'olympia de
manet
ce tableau je laime particulièrement les
français ne connaissent pas puisqu'il
est à saint-pétersbourg et à mon avis il
symbolise très très bien l'art de sésame
cette exposition cézanne est
effectivement la première grande
exposition rétrospective qui montrent
tous les aspects de l'oeuvre de sézanne
qu'il y ait eu à paris depuis 1936 je
crois qu une des révélations de cette
exposition c'est qu'on va retrouver en
chair et en os si je vous dis des
oeuvres qu'on connaît à plat sur des
reproductions temps des livres ce qui
est très trompeur trompeur cézanne
l'était aussi
voyez comme ils trichent avec la
perspective voilà il représente sa table
le pas mis sur la table
et alors à la faveur du temps chanté
pour premier plan il va surélever la
table après l'adoption en surélevant la
table dans la toile qui est
rectangulaire
il la pousse vers le haut celle lui
permet de mettre le panier plus haut
dans la toile et si on décide en
perspective on s'aperçoit que le bagne
et reposant lui d' doumba la ville
déborde mais il masque sa supercherie
par dépôt des poires des fruits etc qui
sont devant donc on ne le voit pas ses
ellipses ont quelquefois vue dessus et
quelquefois vue à hauteur des yeux
voilà la tricherie de sézanne la
tricherie de l'habileté césar
remarquable également la construction
triangulaire des baigneuses dont picasso
se souviendra en peignant les
demoiselles d'avignon
avec un acharnement inouï à l'écart de
tout cézanne révolutionne l'art de
peindre il maîtrise les sensations qu'il
éprouve il ne peint pas la nature il
l'art concours